lucas giolito going to the hill against
the team that he's been very dominant
against the last start that lucas made
against cleveland on the 13th of april
really dominant seven innings no runs on
three hits he'd love to match that
performance here today it's a cleveland
team that he has handled well in his
career as there's a swing and a miss on
the change up and lucas has his first
strikeout johnson hasn't seen the change
up this is his first look at lucas and
if you haven't seen it it's really tough
to deal with because it looks like a
strike for a long time now jose ramirez
who has hit in 12 of his last 14 games
he gets the fastball and ropes it into
right field down the line into the
corner jose is on his way to second base
and he has a two out double so there's a
guy who goes up with a plan he gets the
fastball first pitch and he didn't miss
it and digging in is the d.h today eddie
rosario
swings and sends a ground ball to the
shortstop charged by anderson
his throw is true to abreu and that's it
the indian stranded man at second base
zach please sack on the mountain coming
off a good start against minnesota he
was much more aggressive after he had
lost two starts in a row to chicago
pounding the strike zone out of his 93
pitches 64-strike here's robert adding
second today as adam eaton gets a day
off
ramirez got a hustle that double clutch
will cost him and luis robert trips down
first and you hope he's all right oh my
goodness luis robert takes a spill down
the first base line he does not appear
to be okay don't know if he landed
awkwardly on the bag or not but he is
hurting big time he actually started
limping before he ever got to first base
so that lets you know it's something
serious because he hadn't even leaped
for the bag
prior to starting to go down yeah he's
right now looks like grabbing the the
groin area
on the inside of the right leg he cannot
put any pressure on the right leg so he
is being helped off the field adam eaton
will come on and pinch run for him with
one down in the first month d.h today
and he elevated the fastball to strike
him up yeah nice sequence he came back
with
pretty much the first heater he saw and
he all the changes were down in the zone
and he went the other way he went
fastball up and you can see 93 is going
to get by you wake sucks and indian
scoreless going to the second defensive
changes for the sox here in the second
with the injury to louise robert it'll
be larry garcia moving to center adam
eaton into right runs for either team
but the indians have a runner at second
full count on bowers
3-2 change-up
eaton
a good read on that ball
and mid stride reaches out to save a run
in the banner andres jimenez 2-2 pitch
fly ball to right eating back still
going back he's on the warning track
dirt he hauls it in
that'll do it for the indians
in a second it's the bottom half of
ending number two now he faces the white
sox jake lamb swing and a miss
lamb chased a pitch that was up
strikeout number two for zach please
sack two innings in the books number
nine hitter austin hedges will lead off
the third inning
strike three
there's a slider there's a slider we'll
probably start to see a few more of
those as the indians adjust to what
lucas is doing today back to the top of
the order cesar hernandez
[Applause]
hung that one a little bit deep center
field back as garcia on the track at the
wall it's gone a home run
cesar hernandez with his second homer of
the year
and puts the indians on top one to
nothing cesar hernandez breaks an 0 for
10 skid with a solo shot to dead center
it'll bring to the plate daniel johnson
2-2 swinging a miss he got him on a
change up in the dirt third strikeout
for geolito
we go to the bottom of the third
tonight out of meetings first at bad he
replaces luis robert official word is a
hip flexor strain x-rays negative he
will be reevaluated tomorrow
3-2 up and out ball four
two-one walk for eaton to bring up
monkatta
long and bad for monkata and the crowd
appreciates it now on a double eaton can
score from first because he's going to
be off with the pitch
bowers that's the ball first and the
ball goes down the line
eden is into second base and there's
nobody occupying the base bowers had
just backed off with a 3-2 count he was
just moving back and please sack didn't
realize it yeah you really have to let
the pitcher know what's going on so now
zach wiesek has gotten extremely erratic
with his command two walks in a hit by
pitch three straight batters and it's up
to jake lamb swing and a miss elevated
the fastball please sack slamming his
fist into his glove and he works out of
it leaving the bases loaded three in the
books one down here is ahmed rosario
digs in and he lines one down the right
field line fairball headed into the
corner extra bases for rosario flying to
second and he's gonna try for three here
comes the relay he slides in head first
safe a triple for ahmed rosario
and what a start to his day
with a single and a triple
and with one out the indians have a
runner at third that's good hustle
a chance to uh you know put another run
on the board
and it swung on popped him up
high in the air left side of the infield
settling under it the shortstop anderson
and he's running into by montana the
ball drops and rosario will come home
from third and score
lack of communication between montana
and anderson and as they bumped into
each other the ball drops and the
indians take advantage of the miscue now
jimenez at the plate
high heat gets rid of jimenez quickly
two out
two down for hedges
swinging a miss hedges swung at that
pitch because it was about halfway to
the plate on a change up that was a
beauty from gia lito and we go to the
bottom of the fourth vaughn
stops at second base
and the sox have two on with two out for
tim anderson swing and a miss strike
three got him with a change up perfectly
placed and the side is retired and sox
come up empty again as please act stays
tough we head to the fifth two nothing
try runners on the corners two outs in
the fifth indians already leading two
nothing and naylor trying to extend that
lead right here the pitch
a swing and a high pop fly to center
garcia at first wasn't sure where it was
he's got the glasses on he finds the
ball makes the grab midway in the fifth
here's johan moncotta now the 2-2 from
police act
swing and a missed strike three got him
to chase a change up jose abreu steps in
breaking ball swung on and missed strike
three strong inning for plisac sets the
side out in order and we'll head to the
sixth ahmed rosario leading it off
swinging a miss strike three good
comeback by geo yeah nothing better than
uh striking a guy out there felt he was
on his way to first with a walk middle
of the sixth tying run at the plate the
lefty collins
and he skies one in the air foul third
base side ramirez near the tarp near the
stands reaches over makes a great catch
right over the top of the tarp oh what a
play by ramirez
if the tarp isn't rolled up by the
grandstand area routine play but he had
to go
over that tarp land on his belly on it
and hang on what a play and the indians
have a shutout through six now jose
ramirez at least somebody's on base in
front of him this time
the pitch ramirez yanks one high deep to
right this if it stays fair is gone and
it is a home run
jose ramirez the only question was
would it hook but it didn't
and jose ramirez has hit his second
homer in the series
is team high eighth four nothing have a
one out base runner here in the seventh
here's amanda rosario a trouble in the
single two for three
loop toward right
and that will drop coming around third
base rosario he is gonna score diving
back to first safely
is ahmed rosario and the indians have
scored three times here in the seventh
inning that's nice to see him edgar have
a nice day that's his third hit james
karaczek pitching for the second time in
the series
swinging a miss fastball running away
moncada had no chance one down that'll
bring up jose abreu
no match
karen check strikes him out two down 11
and a third innings 24 strikeouts here's
jake lamb curveball he chased it it
bounced in there dug out by hedges
throws to first and karen check strikes
out the side again emmanuel clausse
comes on for the indians and he has been
just absolutely sensational and nick
madrigal is the last hope
ground ball to short
jimenez
the indians come to chicago and take two
out of three from the white sox the
indians get a combined four hit shutout
today